the golden knights decision makers
they're in montana and bill foley's
ranch this week for the nhl draft what
better way to kick off draft day than
when
a little fishing sports director chris
matthews is there that's right he's live
in montana
joining us did you do some fishing today
chris
no we actually did a lot of fishing
yesterday but today we saw some fish
we went around and saw some of the
beautiful sights of this big rancher you
know i'll tell you what there are few
guarantees in life
but we can tell you one guarantee we
guarantee you that the vegas golden
knights will be the only team in all of
sports that will hold its
draft on a cattle ranch here in montana
we are at the rock creek cattle company
this is bill foley's ranch where all the
golden knights top brats are gathering
of course the knights have the 29th pick
in that first round
they have five picks through the seven
rounds of the two-day draft
now we caught up with the knights
general manager kelly mccrimmon
he talked and kind of gave us a sense
what the knights are thinking
heading into the 2020 nhl draft
when you start looking at you know 29
you sort of come up with
you know eight to ten guys that you
think might be
might be in that wheelhouse but you have
to have done the work
on the players ahead of that in case
someone falls or in case there's an
opportunity
you know a player has slipped a little
bit you'd like to trade up to a choir
um you know so there's a there's it's a
it takes on a life of its own in terms
of working the draft
and the strategy that goes uh behind it
but
it's based on evaluations and putting
together
that final list which which we've now
had in place for some time
all right so the vegas gold knights as
we mentioned had that 29th pick now
nothing is set in stone they could trade
up trade down trade the pick away
so we'll see what happens as they get
ready for the nhl draft
of course up here at the rock creek
cattle company it's beautiful
coming up in about 25 minutes you know a
lot of las vegas are talking about that
brand new
golden knights gold sweater bill foley
likes it a lot we'll tell you
how much he likes that what he'd like to
do with it that's coming up in about 25
reporting from
boy i'll tell you what it's beautiful
out here the rock creek cattle company
in montana
chris matthews eight sports now